we have breaking news from london where
this morning britain's conservative
party unveiled liz trust as the party's
new leader and the country's new prime
minister she and her newly appointed
cabinet will have to hit the ground
running the british people facing a
series of difficult problems in the
months ahead trust replaces boris
johnson who stepped down after a series
of scandals holly williams is in london
outside the houses of parliament holly
good morning
liz truss was not elected by the british
public but instead by around 200 000
rank-and-file members of the
conservative party it's very different
from the u.s system of government but
it's how they do things over here
liz truss will not be britain's first
female prime minister but it's third and
some say she's modeling herself on
another conservative british leader the
iron lady herself margaret thatcher i
can lead i can make tough decisions and
i can get things done
trust has served as the uk's first
female lord chancellor the cabinet
minister in charge of the courts and
most recently as foreign minister taking
a lead role in britain's support for
ukraine putin's premeditated pre-planned
and barbaric invasion
she was an accountant before she entered
politics and her biggest challenge will
be the economy inflation hit a 40-year
high in july heating bills are about to
spike and there have been strikes around
the country
trust has promised deep tax cuts which
economists say will only fuel the
inflation the last few years have been
the greatest privilege of my life
britain's ruling conservative party
ousted its former leader boris johnson
after a series of scandals saw his
popularity plummet hasta la vista
baby
truss wants to rebuild public trust in
her party but has been criticized as
socially awkward and a political
lightweight she was widely mocked for
this impassioned outburst in 2015 about
cheese
we import two-thirds of our cheese
that is a disgrace
liz truss won't formally become prime
minister until she's been to see the
queen who's currently around 500 miles
from here at her scottish home balmoral
castle that meeting will happen tomorrow
ed
and holly that is a break with tradition
i mean the queen is it's done this about
15 times but always at buckingham palace
is the palace saying why it has to
happen in scotland
well you're absolutely correct normally
the queen would come back to buckingham
palace to meet with a new prime minister
it's been reported here in the uk that
she's staying in balmoral castle because
she's been experiencing those same
health issues mobility issues that we
know she's been suffering from for
several months now
motto for liz trust was in liz we trust
yeah here at cbs it's in holly we trust
i trust and we thank you this morning
we'll see you soon